le washington post nous révèle que le
service des archives nationales
américaines a dû rapatrier à la
mi-janvier 15 cartons de documents de la
résidence floridienne de donald trump à
destination de son siège à washington
des documents que donald trump aurait dû
leur remettre à la fin de son mandat
comme le veut une loi américaine parmi
les documents lettres de son
prédécesseur barack obama ou encore des
lettres échangées avec le leader
nord-coréen à kim jong-un le service des
archives nationales affirme continuer à
travailler avec les équipes de l'ancien
président pour rapatrier d'autres
documents ce même service qui a
également indiqué que des documents
officiels avaient été déchirés par
donald trump ce qui là aussi est
interdite par une loi américaine alors
la sphère pourrait paraître quelque peu
anecdotique et maison c'est que l'ancien
président républicains s'opposent au
transfert d'un certain nombre de ces
documents par les archives nationales à
destination de cette commission d'
enquête parlementaire qui enquête
justement sur les événements du 6
janvier 2021 au capitole cette
commission a qualifié de chasse aux
sorcières par donald trump souhaite
obtenir toute information relative aux
agissements de l'ancien président lors
de cette journée du 6 janvier 2021 alors
pour finir sur la sphère des documents
qui ont été non transmis par donald
trump donald trump n'est pas le premier
président à ne pas respecter la loi en
vigueur comme le rappelle là encore le
washington post en 2001 le couple
clinton avait quitté la maison blanche
avec vingt-huit mille dollars de biens
expliquant qu'il s'agissait de cadeau
personnel vous avez finalement dû les
remettre au service national des parcs
naturels américain